hello nice to meet you guys and congrats
on the show
thank you so much so i have a feeling
after everybody binges this they're
going to want to learn
more about midori asap so because both
of you got to share scenes with her
what is it about the way she works on
set that makes her an ideal scene
partner
um midori is very um
uh she's very thoughtful in her in her
in her process
as you would say but she's very fun she
and she's she's open to playing she has
a
she has a very i don't know if other
people i mean other people obviously
know this but to me she has a very
like powerful laugh that kind of starts
small and just gets bigger
she'll sort of go like and you're just
you're like oh
oh but it's very fun she's she's
wonderful
she's she's she's great she really
tapped into her character and really
wanted to
to get it perfect so i think both her
and austin were on a perfectionist like
like tip when i was when i would work
with them but
me being a perfectionist as well i
i thought it came across and me being a
like a deep looking into how people go
into their act
and and go into their roles and do their
things she really tapped in and
would really concentrate and focus on
what needed to be done and she would
go and ask joe all the time is this
right is this is this going right it's
just
and and and so it just pulls everything
together and i think you can see
how hard she worked on getting
everything right from the skip
from like the turnarounds everything
that she did was like
really on point you didn't name drop the
dance though
that might have been one of the best of
the bunch the dance
with the elbow elbow she went crazy
she went him like that's that was one of
my favorite scenes like so
i can't dance but i feel like if i steal
some of her moves it might be okay
yeah my god mike you might do some
things one of my favorite
parts of this story is the idea of
sharing hobbies and how sharing your
favorite hobby with someone else
might bring something new or good out of
them so
what is a hobby that the two of you have
that you might put in a notebook like
this that could bring the best out of
someone else
i would i would i would have sent
whoever to an improv
class because that's that's that's hot
or cold they either love it or that's
their worst nightmare
so you can really read someone that's
pretty sick um
me um i don't know
i would probably send them to like a
studio or or have them like
meet one of my friends that records and
see how well they do
in in that atmosphere and around people
so that's i would probably send somebody
to a party or something with my friends
and see how well we do with that
adventure
my anxiety level is through the roof
right now so i feel like you both nailed
that answer
i also love i love celebrating holidays
period and i love
how this movie really gets into the
christmas spirit but any holiday of your
choice
what is the most unique holiday
tradition you have for me christmas
and not and that's not even just like
saying christmas it's christmas
because my family we all it's like we
come home
it's like a reunion like family from out
of town we got a family like
like that stays on that block and then
we all come to my grandma's house
from youngest to oldest they they rip
open their presents savagely
like and then we'll go to like the
basement of my grandparents house and
we'll like
throw a party dj's there all types of
stuff so it's it's super lit
like my family's my family here
that sounds like a plastic it's lit
my family on my dad's side my japanese
family
growing up all of the aunts and uncles
would write a christmas play
and then make all of the cousins perform
it for just them
um and it was it's everything
and nothing that you can imagine it was
there was one time where we did the
nativity scene and then there was
another time where we were
we were the christmas tree and i was the
star and i just like stepped forward and
did this monologue where i was the star
i don't remember any of it i've blocked
it all out but i know that it happened